hello party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
talk about the show where we talk about
someone else's show dan Merle's here
hello Daniel Radford's here and I'm Jo a
nine-year-old boy we're talking
fantastic beasts - today it's a bad
movie I don't usually like to just play
all the cards I usually like to have a
little more nuance yeah yeah I was not
enamored of it Oh certainly I you know
it's you remember how much you liked the
Harry Potter movies let's do that but
then drain them of all joy and fun yeah
and laughter yep it's literally like
someone opened Harry Potter in Photoshop
and just took all the levels of color
down and yeah it's it's and it's it's
just so messy yes yes just it's just two
and a half hours of things mm-hmm just
stuff and and people people who are
these people
sayings and stuff happening and people
yeah just kind of walking into a room
and some going into a story for no
reason yeah just very little of it has
to do with beasties
this open a book and talk to someone
you've never seen before and this is
that Jessica why using I closed the
buggy like wait what's going on yeah she
dressed that for lunch
I loved it though here's some here's
Hogwarts here's some sad flashbacks and
Hogwarts here yeah this is um this is a
rough rough movie and I think this this
team and especially likes Spencer hated
this movie so much it hurt him so much
that he took a break from caring for his
new baby it's true to write a section
Spencer in over 200 then I have a baby
now that baby is healthy yes nor should
we have known oh yeah and he unbidden
writes it was just like I had
to write this I have to go change
diapers and be a father but I had this I
had to send you this yeah that came in
Friday night yeah and so we shifted some
stuff around yeah let's just jump let's
just jump right into this dive into
it'll tear this sucker apart as we go
[Music]
you love JK rowling through the harry
potter years you knew her mystery novels
weren't just a phase you swore curse
child was better live he defended her
right to a tweaks and character details
after the fact
you looked past all the flaws of the
first fantastic beasts to see its
potential and now this this is how you
repay our loyalty I am done standing for
you Jake a fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald so pause that was the
fevered email that we received well I
mean Spencer is one of the core group he
is absolutely he and Ross are the two
Potterheads yeah but Spencer from the
beginning I mean going back to our
original Harry Potter trailer was always
the one who was hardest on Harry Potter
because he loved it so much yeah yeah he
hates Quidditch
because he loves Harry Potter yeah I
understand his pain this movie makes me
never want to wear my Hufflepuff scarf
again okay and I like I love that
Hufflepuff scarf this movie makes me
never want to wear a suit so yeah this
is a bummer this whole thing's a bust a
downer just to get to the end of it and
I was like and even every when there are
moments that are like fun and silly it's
because it directly leads to something
horrible and terrible yes right like um
you know that whole first bit with
Queenie and what's-his-name where
they're doing a really fun comedy and
everything's really silly yeah um you
know they're doing all these weird gags
it's like haha he can't hold things in
minutes because she has taken away all
of his consent yeah and free will and
free will yeah because she desires to
marry him against his like woody did not
have permission yeah and so it's like
okay well you took this really fun beat
and now it's really weird and sad and
awkward yeah even the Ministry of Magic
watching you know that's one point
there's a little funny little vacuum
cleaner thing yes the suits bite I'm
like oh that's some cute Harry Potter
magic but then later then the Ministry
of Magic and there's these old ancient
Wizards hunched over these big carts
heavy book carts pushing them through
and I'm just like wow how come the
vacuum cleaners get magic things but
you're making these ancient old tired
weary old Wizards push these heavy ass
parts of books around I can't mana is an
a Keo spell like every bit of happiness
leads to have more more much of a downer
question down the line yeah credence is
back but he's even even he's somehow
even sadder dad yeah I don't know how
you did it cuz the first one I saw
Creedence is an allegory for child abuse
like the what are they called the the
orb that you turn into the the evil
magic orb thing whatever it's called I
can't remember now I saw that as an
allegory for child abuse and I don't
know how you get much darker than that
but somehow they did it where even just
his posture he's hunched over more in
this one and his like haircut is even
harsher oh I was gonna say he's working
a circus he got a very stylish haircut
from the last film in the circus you're
thinking yeah man wizard circus this
sounds dope
oh no people in cages can you think of
any two words put together that some
happier than Wizards Circus Circus
Oh wizard circus misery instead cages
here do this she's gonna turn into a
snake so she better keep doing this oh
God
let's keep go right circle world of
harry potter a place we're trying to
kill a baby just marked him as a row
okosan one now visit a new chapter where
they just kill babies as The Wizarding
World
it's a turn toward a dark universe for
the bleakest wet is darkest chapter yet
ok WB suck all the joy out of Harry
Potter for Aquaman it's the same cuz if
this series ends up with Jacob blowing
up the Ministry of Magic with a sharpie
I'm gonna be very upset pause and you
can always tell I wrote it if it's a
long sentence that it was possibly proud
to say sorry sorry about that buddy he's
got some great reads in this one by the
way why it's so weird that like Warner
Brothers course-corrected the DC movies
they're more fun than crazy they're like
they're silly mm-hmm they're colorful
but I do feel like they Bunnicula doll
of that color and and and whimsy out of
Harry Potter like why can't I'm starting
to think that there's like a picture of
dorian gray situation in the basement
cuz it's not it's not that it's not
always the same franchise at Warner
Brothers it's just that it's some
franchise that were your brothers that
just takes a turn toward misery and yeah
anger dark-blue meanness and always yeah
and they move it around it's like
there's some couture turret has a finite
amount of joy right and and it must dry
draws its power from sadness and anger
so they must then throw it into the
public eye it's bizarre look at it it's
called fantastic beasts and where to
find them
yeah where are my fantastic beasts
except for you know this was notice they
have those little triples but that's all
we get and a woman who again turns into
a snake that will become a snake forever
this where is
I want make it like Pokemon it's so much
fun make them cute o little beasts
whatever instead we get wizard Hitler
yes it's a it's why our our know if if
the point of this was the story of how
new releases his textbook why is it
every movie just send her around a beast
shenanigan and some kind of story you
know revolves around that and and it's
fun I think there doesn't mean devoid of
substance I think their shenanigans
going on I think JK Rowling wanted to
write the prequel to the Harry Potter
people like you know what prequels are
because it's kind of going to style
exert anything else is didn't she's like
yes you have this book fantastic beasts
and where to find I want to write a
series about fantastic animals and
wondrous adventures finding all of them
and Warner Bros is like yes featuring
characters from Harry Potter yeah okay
and at the end of it we introduce
Grindelwald like okay but we already
said yes so we can't say no I was like
and the second one is about him rising
to be the dark wizard she turns into the
infrared of this what's happening
fantastic beasts and I'll get to them
later yeah yeah was something I I didn't
put into this draft which I had meant to
which was because it's what a the main
thing I've been thinking about this
whole time is that the this is an
instance where everyone was either too
scared to tell her no or just weren't
allowed to because of her contract right
yeah and it's just one of those things
where it's like being surrounded by yes
folk is not necessarily good for art
yeah yeah I don't see changing some
stuff around yeah because I don't want
to hear about any more wizard hate
crimes I just want the beasts and I want
to know where to find them I'll tell you
this I'll even take your wizard hate
crimes if you can give them to me in a
narrative that makes sense like if you
can get me from a logical point A to
point B mm-hmm
where it's like where it's like I
hypnotized you so we could come to
London to get married because it's legal
for us to get married in London and then
now I'm gonna join Johnny Depp because
he wants us to be able to get married
even though we can get married where we
are right now and even though with my
own eyes I've seen him say that he
thinks humans should
like but he no literal offices gave a
very long monologue about how he wants
the literal opposite of what you want
just call your husband like a rodent
basically different just different yeah
that's bad that's bad would say like
well but that's how traditionally that's
how evil has sold itself and I will
agree that is that is definitely true
but he is still very much openly about
pureblood yes I'm just saying there's
not a lot of lines to read between there
yeah there's nothing wrong with a bad
guy or man yeah like there's nothing
wrong with that villainous plan except
for the weird it will get into it will
get into it but but it's everyone's
reaction to it makes zero sense we're
gonna be here for three days yeah let's
go continue all your favorite characters
from the first fantastic beasts are back
like Newt Scamander
who's gone from awkward beast lover to
awkward chick magnet okay stop awesome I
irrationally upset about this if why is
every woman in this series in love with
Newt Scamander what are they seeing that
I'm it's the Archie thing where it's
just I mean now obviously Archie is hot
because we decided we wanted hot Archie
but if you go back and look at some of
those old he looked like Newt Scamander
which is fine but he's not interested
he's very blatantly uninterested in many
of them except for one but they cannot
help but say you know like ooh you so
hot it's it's Daniel is it because the
terse is it because they can fix him oh
man in this Harry Potter yes if it was
any other version it would be because
he's so charming and he's so passionate
about what he loves but we didn't get
that
so yeah in this version it is because
you know it is weird that they met I say
okay let's talk assistant lady because
this is her like one thing she does in
this movie why did you do set character
what is the point of hurt like right
you're gonna come back in part three I
will I will say this and I love Harry
Potter love Harry Potter like the boy
on all the books like the movies on all
the movies Washington multiple times
however this is kind of a JK Rowling
thing where the arcs between male
characters and female characters are
generally kept to will they or won't
they do they like each other or you out
they and when they end up together or
won't they yeah Harry Hermione which I I
would argue the movies did a little more
of a will they were very not what they
want they but but but definitely
directly address their relationship a
little more directly as far as like how
they interact between two humans yeah
yeah but there are a lot of the the a
lot of the girl Hogwarts students and
the boy Hogwarts students were
ultimately boiled down to do that do
they like this person and will they not
accept Luna who's a great character he's
a great actor she's just totally off but
then even there it's like and then she
married Neville I think it makes sense
yeah makes sense yeah her Petronas was
not the Bechtel test let's keep going
hats girl it's probably his lizard based
love interest she has eyes just like a
salamander don't say that
bastard mix maker Jacob who's still
making those faces and the dreamy
Queenie who heroically hypnotizes and
kidnaps her boyfriend I'm curious when
you were gonna wake me up after we had
five kids huh well at least she didn't
join forces with wizard Hitler this is
another one I say things happen that's
something in this movie that just sort
of happened and they they kind of they
provide you with the reason why the
movies does it happened but you're
saying it doesn't make that much sense
why ultimately she would make that
decision
yeah it's cuz she cried in the rain one
time yeah it's really sad the one
henchman number three no she she had
like the Marty McFly thing about being
called crazy yeah I guess the only the
only justification is by doing the the
hypnotizing him into wanting to get
married
and taking away his free will she is
showing that she is capable of being
evil then just show her turn evil don't
make it about their relationship which
is not which is a love that cannot be
make it about her slowly doing things
because it's you know it's that
selfishness in her right it starts
turning her and I think that's what hit
me wrong was her her the only motivation
that she was given to the whole movie is
she wants to be with Jacob yeah that she
and she wants to marry Jacob he had
reservations cuz he's like listen you're
kind that like my kind and it doesn't
mention so she tried to hypnotize him so
that he forgot about that and she was
gonna marry him and then when did they
snapped him out of it then he went back
to saying like you can't like this is
not gonna this is not good like I don't
think you're thinking this through and
then but that remained her motivation to
the point where she joined the one
person who will not allow that to happen
so that completely goes against her
entire motivation throughout the film
like even before she goes through the
fire her motivation only is still I want
to be with you but then she takes
actions that preclude her completely
from being that's what I mean it's like
there needs to be more I wish there had
been more to her story yeah yes to why
she did that other than just I like this
guy and I want to be yeah but like what
what other parts of her yes are are
enchanted by this what is the door that
opens and it's just because they're
doing 47 other things in this film it's
like Johnny Depp talks to her in the
drawing room for a minute for a second
this guy that she's seen kill people
right and be horrible while we're on
them
Jacob and Queenie a my love for JP walls
he is well documented yeah honor his
channel how did you make me not like him
very much because I turn into a plot
device oh my god my there's there's
somebody I'd also like this the dumb
explanation of of what happened to him
that my favorite two things in the first
movie that make me overlook everything I
didn't like about the movie is one his
sad moment when he he's discovered this
world he steps out into that rain that
kills his memories and then the
beautiful hopeful moment where she comes
into the bakery and through the power
love she like he overcomes the magic
that's that's how he remembers
yeah that should be happy that's it
that's a and then they had come in he's
like oh well it only erases bad memories
and my memories and it's like no it's so
beautiful that he overcame magic cuz he
loves her so much what are you doing and
if it's only bad memories did Hermione
Granger's parents hate her to erase
herself from their lives and they should
have remembered their daughter if they
liked her oh there's all kinds of spell
issues in this there's the Ironman
Holograms spell like you blow a bunch of
dust around and it shows you everything
that happened at the scene of the at any
given place like 12 hours before which
would have been useful in any number of
situations like almost every Harry
Potter movie involved where is some I
need someone was here but now I need to
find them like a little yeah and you see
everything like the spells became plot
devices the characters became devices we
bothered we wrestled with getting this
into the trailer it didn't end up coming
in and I we gotta move on I apologize
but yeah we talked about the spell
I kinda suppose just felt like super
here just vague superhero powers in this
movie versus like in Harry Potter it was
like even the ex like the master wizards
and witches had very certain spells you
know what they were doing motions and
incantations yeah and like what's the
spell that throws a guy across a room
makes a chair up here and then ties him
to the chair and then pushes the chair
back like what's that did you expect on
it anyone that the first movie
established as the main characters of
the series because this one spends most
of its time with characters you've never
met or cared about now with multiple
flashbacks of this lady's traumatic
childhood her love triangle with nude
and his grim suit wearing brother the
mission of this groom swearing assassin
and this grim suit wearing man who's
hunting this grim suit wearing boy from
the first one come on
so movie is just grim-faced people in
suits talking even Dumbledore is just
Jude Law looking grim in a suit we just
go back to Ron Weasley making dumb faces
at stuff what
[Music]
thanks Weasley the boss yeah oh the good
old days
yeah Leda Lestrange was a photo and a
name in the first movie and this one
introduces her like as the protagonist
yeah like jump on board she's been the
protagonist of all time all this family
backstory that has nothing to do with
anything well I mean except that it's a
part of the bigger world it's it's
that's when they introduced Leda I
thought that I because I had not
rewatched the first film the first time
that I saw the second foam I hadn't
watched the first one in a while and I
just assumed that they had introduced
Leda in the firt like actually
introduced her in the first one and then
I'd forgotten because she literally just
walks into the movie like hey what's
going on how you doing new it anyway
this was just like oh wait I must have
forgotten no it's just literally it's
like if in Iron Man 2 Don Cheadle had
had his big intro shot and was like yeah
it's me get over it but Warmachine
hadn't been in Iron Man 1 is how it like
walks in in MIDI and they're already
best friends yeah ok and their whole the
whole thing with it with him and Tina
and not - yeah Tina is like it's based
on a mistake and a misprint in a
newspaper that like what yeah that's the
whole the only thing that is keeping
these two you know Scamander and
salamander eyes apart is that something
there was a weird gossip page where they
talk about the fantastic beasts guy I
guess ORS are all the rage and everyone
wants to know what the ORS are up to and
the gland but so mentioning that he had
gotten engaged right to her but had not
and so neptina is upset all of this
could have been taken care of through a
letter probably yeah there are a house
or if I deposit a stronger screenplay
that establishes conflict between
characters on screen instead of a random
anonymous off-screen event that happened
before we haven't caught up at the movie
again doesn't that seem like that would
be kind of a fun wacky thing oh it's
kind of fun wacky there was a misprint
now people think we're engaged but no
once again it's dark and depressing yeah
cuz even their relationship could be
charming because the first movie
honestly was because she's odd he's
completely strange and I love the idea
of everyone
just being like I don't get it but I'm
glad they're happy like that's a fun
idea to me and it's they all had to get
to ignore that so they could all go to a
meeting a crypt and talk for 25 minutes
now that was another thing that didn't
make any more just talking about ideas
but like Star Wars prequel crimes it's
all just sitting and standing and
sitting and standing and politics and
sitting and standing it's like why why
do you think that that's what I want out
of a I you know maybe they thought this
was Magic Chinatown and we really needed
to get into who was whose brother no
whose brother is whose brother and whose
dad was a bad I don't need it no no
let's be real but while everyone else is
grimly talking the evil grindelwald is
also mostly just talking in living rooms
on roofs in alleys in creepy auditoriums
and while overlooking mountains at a
very swanky ski lodge all to unveil his
master plan to prevent World War two
there our lust how long will it take
before they're turning their weapons on
us wait what so what you're saying is
that wizard Hitler make some good points
is there a Hogwarts Express off this
franchisor suppose let's talk about the
world war two thing blanket statement I
understand that he's using this as a
larger manipulation to give me a blunt
aside I get that yes but a tying the
like Harry Potter works in its own weird
charming silly way because it is
divorced from the real world anytime
with Harry Potter book someone's like
book how does this affect I'm like I
don't care it's about hot war it's a
Terry Potter shut up you're overthinking
it but when you directly tie the movies
there are the stories into the real
world
then you've opened yourself up to it and
it's like why'd didn't Wizards want to
prevent World War 2 and the Holocaust
and like the Chinese like yeah this is
our version of the Twitter wizard toilet
yeah yeah
these are just different bombs dropping
or this is somewhere where they cuz the
best part about that was when they're
watching that and Jacob like horrified
because he someone had to deal with it
the most out of all of them just yes
another war yeah he was in the great
ones Jews in the great war he's like
he's a muggle he lives in this world and
they could have done something really
like if they'd use that and maybe both
Jacob and Queenie Joe and Grindelwald so
they're still together Jacob has actual
motivation to join Grindelwald because
he's like whoa I don't like what this
guy selling but if this is true and this
is what fall on this guy is gonna
prevent or at least like so I can escape
this somehow then maybe I need
everything my position but that's that's
not the way they go and yeah I get the
thing so yeah I'll Grindelwald
manipulating them like I can I get that
by yourself in a weird corner but it's
yeah we're the initial reaction for the
good guys has to be like no that stuff's
fine we hate you you know like it or
even the fact that it comes that it then
comes to pass or to still happens right
unless we find out after the fact that
Harry Potter took place in a really
weird alternate 90s inglorious basterds
yeah oh god if wizards are added to the
tarantino verse i'm in i think i'm kind
of yeah okay alright I mean world war ii
obviously still happened different
version yeah but and you're just and
even just connecting you're like well
now now it's all thrust together now we
have to just ask all basic questions
like why why aren't wizards just out in
the open and they're like we're wizards
you can't really do anything about it
because you can't hurt us you can't kill
us
let's go watching this physically hurts
Geoff so toss away your wizard robes and
welcome to competent job for a fantastic
beast movie that's light on the beasts
but fantastically depressing and start
hoping for a chosen one to show up and
save this franchise because they're
still three more of these logs to go
tell me my story than you can end it
know what I'm tapped down on fantasy
prequels Oh what else is on Game of
Thrones and Lord of the Rings prequels
follow me once all you would never pay
potty pause shield he's not just pale
he's a she and I think that's the
Poppins maybe the most he is not just
pale very dry very much needs chapstick
his voice needs chapstick in this movie
it's rough alright give Sheldon Cooper
hey I'm American or a story a high
schooler is gonna be head this lady
someday fine Jude Law as Jude Law the
greater good attempting to remember the
names of any of these new characters Lee
Leslie the sad faces
Eva Branagh Kedavra and wriggly sweat
fest Eva Braun jokes I've never made a
oh let's get no Frenchie Mick mystery
add your name written in glory
cool cool but uh like what are their
names
her dark material IRA told me Robert
hope he nailing it
they even to Johnny Depp to introduce
vaping to the Wizarding World
so the Nagini thing is another example
of my problem with with prequels which
is yes that they're obviously setting
her up she's on the side of good good
obviously setting her up as some kind of
a tragic character this is this this
right as of now is the the appearance
seems to be here's this good person
tragic person with this blood curse
she's gonna be a snake someday and she's
gonna be developed throughout the rest
of these movies okay if that's the way
you want to go with it but the problem
is Neville like like moments in the
history of Harry Potter yeah that's just
like Neville yes I did not know that was
a thing he so that's the reason he when
they shot Voldemort
that's like yes yes that is awesome and
then and now now it's like oh but I feel
bad for Nagini like no you're supposed
to feel bad for Nagini I suppose feel
bad for anybody in that moment like that
is like a fist pump moment yeah and now
it's gonna be tense with like but she
was really a tragic figure guys it's
like yeah stop putting your dumb tweets
into the stuff now like she I that's
that's another reason why I really hate
that she's now had got like creative
control over these movies and gets to
keep going because I've never liked
these weird after-the-fact changes she
makes because put them in your books put
them in you wrote books put them in the
books stopped doing rewrites on Twitter
yeah it drives me insane now but now she
can like do it with a big budget and
it's just it's it's just I don't yeah
neguin ease of the weird one to me
especially because yeah like there's no
way there's no way that you had even
thought about that because you would
have looked at that cut because I know
there was shown her dailies and I know
you know she was a producer on the film
no way she looks at that and goes can we
shoot that differently because Nagini is
a lady and you're gonna find out later
no that's why these are my least
favorite kinds of prequels when you go
through and you fill in gaps the lor
because ultimately indican five friend
Chewbacca yes
it's gonna conflict' in some way with
something that came before it and calls
all these weird issues tone issues to
arise and it's the thing that I was most
appealing about to me when I heard about
fantastic peace was like oh this is
gonna be like a new corner of the Harry
Potter universe I've never seen before
and then less than a movie we're right
back to like no this is just gonna
sketch in details what you are in the
saddest parts of David Yates Harry
Potter movies it's just more it's just
work did the misery of the end of Harry
Potter which by the way was earned
because you had the joy at the beginning
and it was a slow progression into the
dark wizard world at the end let's just
use that dark part was that yeah and
it's like yeah completely that was what
I wanted I wanted a fun silly adventure
that gets us to open up more of the
world and more of these things where
again you could have put the things that
you tweeted about except of course was
our toilets never needed to know
anything about those that was a good old
title just wizard toilet it's really
it's so upsetting but yeah that's I
completely agree with you it's you had
such an opportunity here to really show
us the world some of the things that
have been on the website some of the
things that have been up in other books
you know that would have been to me that
was also what was interesting about this
I don't want to re-litigate the wizard
wars yeah but that's what you're gonna
get for three more movies any more
movies I think we got some deleted
scenes JT indeed we do from Warner
Brothers and writer JK Rowling comes a
confusing long and boring sequel that
proves you can be the JK Rowling of
wizard books and still be the Fifty
Shades lady of spring party
Holmes ARF our first intro and he loved
the Wizarding world's every carefully
constructed need to run JK because now
she's taking crapping on her own
creation from your Twitter feed to the
big screen by wrecking the lore new
prophet seems to destroy you
breaking her timeline guy with Professor
McGonagall please listen are
straightforward Hogwarts adventures with
a plot so dance you'll have to keep the
Harry Potter wiki open while you watch
it there since but the spelling told
time you all the wing I'm the Avenger of
my family's room okay let's see here his
dad loved before this her mom she only
loosely connects to Belgic sand wait why
am i doing homework just let me enjoy a
movie movie that was deleted because
Spencer or that intro that intro which
we thought covered some of the same yeah
it's kind of double dipping a little bit
and the trailer was kind of long yeah we
had some things to say yeah yeah I know
a lot of people say why don't cut
anything labor the point sometimes it
just feels good to get it out there I
could have done a whole run on just him
having a double in prison and then
rescuing his double from a flying
carriage instead of just quietly leaving
the prison and they don't find out that
he's gone for the next five to ten years
but cool cool cool y'all do you we've
got some more starring 'he's grossed
Radames old award B's master beast mode
killer Queenie mm-hmm
Danielle congratulations on your first
cut joke on on Australia
let's all appreciate Robert god bless
Robert Holtby he's incredible yep and he
is very talented and he did this whole
title thing here before the title came
in but it takes a minute and it would
like the the rhythm was a little lost
off yet and so we didn't JT go
fullscreen on this people if you can
this whole thing that he is brilliant
and we just weren't able to include it
this is great we don't deserve or we
don't deserve Robert yeah it is this
conference table always show pictures
being talked about in the room they were
talking about lunch what a shoe a ham
sandwich look I think it's rare that
Dumbledore is gay but I refuse to accept
that his taste in men is a grayscale
Johnny Depp not at the time - yeah still
yeah
younger tastier yes so that that's it
that's the honest trailer perfect has a
piece we did it Dewalt
yeah I don't feel any better Dan no only
because there's three more so it's
whatever I'm putting to bed now I'm just
gonna have to dig back up a couple years
Oh Danielle give me my piece
I just want my B that is what my B's I
want any Grindelwald tiny beets some
chocolate frogs after that Dementor of a
film man that was that was rough
that's it and we think we went kind of
long on this one thank you guys for
hanging in and watching with us what's
happening next week I think it may have
been referenced ooh in this trailer
we'll see you guys then ie
[Music]
you